so you busted me in my hopes of
paternalistic independence now revealed
that unfortunate known shy for a long
time every bit of advice I gave him was
wrong fortunately he ignored all of it I
I mean it's really an extraordinary
story of personal reinvention I mean the
over 22 years ago two and a half years
ago you were a software guy dear
afternoon you're an Afghan worse off
read this is a lifetime software
entrepreneur you know web and and
enterprise software and I was just right
I just came back from Frankfurt this
afternoon and I was riding in the same
same seat that he wrote road what I feel
your pain they wanted before from
Frankfurt he did what twice a month
three times a month yeah I'd cross that
ocean probably two or three times in
those seats everyone it was any wasn't a
tremendous success and then he went to
Davos and had this moment and get to
watch a guy kind of watched lost the
light go off and say wait I'm gonna I'm
gonna completely change the direction of
my career and I'm gonna do something
that no one thinks is possible when
those three smart guys in the room all
thought this was crazy and just powered
through and here we are so it's it's a
you know I've lost all the journalistic
independence I I'm not I'm not I'm not
I can't even admit that I'm sort of on
his side cuz I've been wrong throughout
but I'm gonna try to ask questions that
that I some of them I know the answer to
I met him I don't know the answer to and
I'm going to start with the California
which is brand new um California's many
ways seems like the obvious candidate
it's green you know the the technology
aspects of what you're doing are obvious
the the capital you know sources etc but
in many ways it seems it doesn't have
the advantages of me at some of the
other places we don't tax our cars one
hundred percent the gas is much cheaper
than it is elsewhere we don't have those
kind of you know island where were we
tend to drive beyond California
sometimes um tell tell me about the
economic so how does California compare
to you know Denmark or Israel poorly you
know no I mean there's they're
interesting elements in here so one of
the things that we've identified fairly
early is if you if you go by pure
economics you want to go to the places
where gasoline is priced the highest
where the population is the most dense
and where people actually have more
access to their own parking spots so bay
area has got two out of three okay so we
have our own parking spots by and large
we also have the perfect range extender
it's called the other car right
and we sort of if you if you look at the
Bay Area we've got these big three you
know Oakland San Francisco and San Jose
but in between you you know most people
actually have their own home yeah and
and so if you work with PG&E which is
what we're hoping to do to actually sort
of piggyback their their efforts on
smart metering when you put a smart
meter why not put a smart charge spot in
the same home and that helps on some of
the upfront economics which today are
actually more painful because the word
debt has become a four-letter word right
on the other hand we have a great
advantage to the Bay Area if you go to
any Detroit or Texas and you say we've
got a new product they'll say okay if
you give me fifty percent discount I'll
try it if you come to bury and you say i
got a new product itself even thirty
percent premium to be the first and so
we've got the the innovators advantage
in writing the bear now in israel people
tend to park in parking garages big big
multi-story parking rogers and so there
you've got this sort of easy i presume
like like a a rack of plugs that go
along the bumpers etc so that's kind of
a it's an outside thing it's it's
weather and all that kind of stuff in
the US it's in the it's in the personal
garage right so then you have you know
you have to get people to reconfigure
their their wiring all that kind of
stuff and that's an easier job for you
it's it's a mess on the US its a mix
you've got two anchor points for
everybody it's the place of work and the
place relive the place where you live in
in the west coast is usually your home
garage in the east coast is still
assured parking spot and the place of
work is is always a sort of a garage
type of environment so what we found out
is most of the work we're gonna do is
gonna usually go through large
workplaces this is you know large an HP
Intel Google Yahoo was perfect places
because if you get a list of employees
we're interested you at least know that
you can do there
home parking spot by giving them
something to you know sort of note for
PG&E and you can do the parking lot for
the company and you're done you got to
touch points for for that person so you
either the companies are going to allow
you to put charge spots in their
employee lots they're going to subsidize
the cars some extent as well we hope we
hope okay how will you know where you
know you've driven down to the valley
you know 40 miles you're pretty much at
the end of your range how do you know
where you're gonna there's a spot there
for you so we actually have a piece of
software that resides inside the car and
is connected to a back-end system that
actually knows every single parking spot
who's parked when all kind of stuff we
don't tell anybody there's there's
authentication everything else that goes
on but one of the big things that you're
gonna get if you drive our car into San
Francisco and you say i'm gonna go to
you know this spot you'll tell you here
are the six parking spots you can go
into and you can pick which one will
walk it for you and just that is worth
money so you can reserve a parking place
in San Francisco yes so nice job before
from ahead of time do you what will you
do it as you get closer to that spot you
can sort of get you get your get your
needs the same thing we're doing on
because you need to know this this big
Network to optimize it mmm when you come
in not everybody needs to charge at the
same time engine every employee comes
into yahoo in the morning at eight
fifteen they all plug and all the cars
start charging the servers go down right
so what you want is is you want to know
you know Chris comes into wired early in
the morning doesn't leave until nine
o'clock unless it's Tuesday for some
reason lunch you leave right so we know
that depending on your profile what
priority you are and the charger and
you're paying VIP so you get sort of a
bump up on the charging spots and all
kind of mechanism has done completely
transparent behind the scenes a lot of
software sort of like a Google of
electrons if you want whereas AP Google
all right tell me a little bit about the
car the car we've seen outside is a
four-door sedan relatively modest
etcetera is that gonna be the car that
we buy that that's the prototype 2 is
actually a converted SUV it's a we've
seen demand in sort of anchor in two
cars one is a 4 door 5 seat sedan
high-end sedan so people want to feel
like they're driving a new car and in
the first car that's going to come out
is a fairly high end sedan not the one
not the one that you're seeing often we
our goal was to actually have an SUV
with in about 12 months after the sedan
comes out and it will look roughly this
sort of sort of like that not
necessarily like that in in both cases
the battery comes from below mm-hmm and
so as it's it's fairly fun to drive it
sort of 0 to 60 sub-10 it's a high-speed
very very high torque when you compare
it to a gasoline that the same car on
gasoline the electric is about twice
pasture on acceleration so so now when
we when you first started thinking about
this gas was
three dollars gallon ish the commie was
robust the car companies were strong
competitors now the pictures changed
what how does how is you know gas at
forty nine dollars a barrel and GM and
near bankruptcy and the economy on the
two in going down the tubes how does
that change your mouth so so two things
that I did learn since we started when
we start I started 50 yard dinner i
think it was still at fifty dollars a
barrel and and we went up to 147 we came
back to 50 which feels a bit crazy but
what would i did learn is oil is
depleting no matter how you're going to
look at it oil oil is not coming back
into the ground unless we put it back in
the ground we don't know how to put it
back in the ground yet we haven't
figured out it collected from the fumes
and as a result of that what's depleting
is the easy aisle and what we're finding
is the very hard oil and very hard oil
is very expensive to get out of the
ground and so we're sort of on the
sliding scale where the the cheap stuff
is ending and the expensive stuff is
coming up and unfortunately every every
year we're adding 40 million more cars
we having 70 million cars 30 million air
replacement 40 million our new into the
the list of people that want to buy oil
so it's a parabolic curve any which way
you want to look at it at the baseline
on top of it we created an oscillating
curve called the economy when the
economy's robust we go up when the
economy is not robust or dead as we call
it right now it goes down and we now
know what what sort of the the gap is up
is plus 50 down is minus 50 but the
medium right now is about a hundred and
I learned for this there's a great group
called Sarah Cambridge energy research
they're sort of the experts on oil
unfortunately they not always tell you
the truth because they're paid by the
oil companies and but they have a very
interesting saying right now says at
fifty dollars a barrel countries figure
out ways to reduce consumption using
science at one hundred fifty dollars a
barrel countries find ways to secure
supply
their armies and we were that close all
right we were three dollars close we're
finally back to 50 which gives us enough
time to sort of build up infrastructure
big projects to build up supply chain of
these cars and this is fantastic it's
the best thing that ever happened to us
your business model assumes that the
cost of electrons is less than the cost
of gas you your margin basically is the
is the economic advantage of driving
your car as opposed to another what is
the what is the the margin at fifty
dollars she's alright so the
fundamentals of our businesses we buy
batteries and electrons the battery
costs are get you to about four four to
five cents a mile when you sort of take
the entire life of the battery and
electrons cost you between one and two
cents am also including the subsidy for
the car including nothing base no taxes
no no subsidies no giveaways for sense
to 45 cents a mile for the battery 12
sent depending on whether you use pole
or you do what we do which is used wind
and solar two cents so we're roughly at
about six seven cents a mile if you take
the average u.s. consumption about 20
miles per gallon 25 miles per gallon
we're a buck 50 gallon nikkolon if you
want to think of us as electric gasoline
we're a buck 50 a gallon a buck 50
gallon is $25 barrel with no taxation
mm-hmm know if you apply European tax a
buck 50 gallon is minus sixty dollar
gallon minus minus sixty dollar barrel
so we're okay up to zero if you go down
to minus 60 we're still good in the u.s.
I don't think you're going to see a $25
barrel anytime soon so the base the
foundation the economics of what we do
the physics and economics is you guys
bomi are extremely solid now if the
price goes up to four dollars a gallon
we got two and a half dollars
effectively a gallon to play backward
and we're going to give it back to the
consumer the car company to whoever it
is to convince them to get addicted to
electricity that's what we do we get you
addicted till I constant now you said to
the the
source of electricity is gonna be green
yes how do you ensure that we make sure
that on the margin we buy the same
amount of electricity through a massive
long-term power purchase agreement
mm-hmm as the amount of cars we put so
Israel we can you know 2 million cars
needs to gigawatts of solar mm-hmm it
was a great story we went to the
Ministry of infrastructure and and said
you know we want to build a 2 gigawatt
solar plant in the desert they said
that's that's too big and we took a map
and we drew a circle nuh so you guys are
nuts it's it's a giant swath of land and
I said what if I told you that we found
oil in that spot that could drive every
car in the country for the next 50 years
they said but we try to look for it it's
not there yes I don't know what what if
we prove that it's there and said if you
can prove it would let you dig so I said
that we want to dig up we're gonna dig
up and put solar plant and it's what's
interesting is you for every car on the
road you need to put a reflector
effectively the size of the car and that
gives you power to drive that car
forever and if you put the two together
you get a zero carbon footprint infinite
virtual oil field so in Israel you're
not just in the car business and a
battery business and the grid business
but you're also in the solar power 10
we're buying the power from the
generator so we're buying a 12-year
power purchase agreement today something
else is doing this any yeah they do it
and then in California likewise the same
that he will secure yeah the only place
where we don't need to do it is Denmark
it's interesting because Denmark has got
the wind and they don't know how to stop
it at night if you stop a win a windmill
at night it falls into the water yeah
and so you got to let it go but then you
get spikes of electricity at night and
if you don't let it go the grid goes
down so they sell it to the Germans and
they pay them money to take it it's
amazing they actually get times in which
they sell electrons at negative few
cents neck right bill what our and we
when we came in and said to the author
company will take it they're like oh
great you got batteries we love you guys
let's talk about other kinds of electric
cars right now you have a choice between
obviously that's hybrids these are the
hybrids were glad to they are serial
hybrids which is to say that they get to
two engines want a motor and an engine
both connected to transmission you can
get a pure electric car in the form of a
Tesla and then you can have what GM is
designing the vault which is a site
where do parallel hybrids and the Volt
is a serial hybrid which is its only
electric motors attached sort of wheels
and you have a little engine driving
generator if you need it start let's
start let's start with a traditional
hybrid the parallel hybrid of prius etc
what's wrong with that um so I'll tell
you so I got to tell you this story it's
a fantastic story this is Davos 2007
Perry president Paris invited all the
car companies to come and talk to them
because that we didn't have a car
company yet and we invited the top of
the big 53 didn't show up for some one
reason you know but they have to be the
American one no there I think their Jets
didn't make it all the way to Davos the
to the to the did show up we were very
interesting because one showed up and
they'll remain unnamed but after Paris
told him the story they said don't do
this project will give you great
discount on hybrids and for 25 minutes
they try to sell us to do hybrids and
not do electric cars I think Carl was
gone-zo renault-nissan comes in and and
Paris tells him the story again which is
the the great virtue of Paris he thought
he failed to convince the the other guys
so he told it with more vigor in and
then Carlos gone looks at him and says
I'll be your partner will build the car
we can make a fantastic electric car and
so Ferris looks and says you don't want
to do hybrids and this is that's why I
told us we see look it says hybrids are
like mermaids when you want fish you get
a woman you want a woman you get a fish
and if you look at the problem with with
the prius is it's an expensive it's an
expensive car with two drive trains it's
got only one way to put energy into it
and that's oil which gives you sort of a
clue that you're not getting anything
other than a bit more efficient engine
we were California is the highest
adoption rate of priuses the entire
country a thing there's like a million
priuses after 10 years in those ten
years we added 500 million cars into the
population 1 million of them are hybrids
and they're twenty percent more
efficient so we got an open to
improvement on a no point to market
that's not gonna save this planet okay
and that's the number one hybrid in the
world cuz okay so let's what about the
Volt what about thing that the serial
hybrid I think the Volt is is a great
idea I think you just want to plug it
just just yeah it's a plug hybrid so you
can you can run this electric car all
the time you may never have to use the
gas in the tank but if you do need the
guest length there it is the Volt is
fantastic in the sense that if you don't
have infrastructure you can't have an
electric car that stops when you run out
of juice and so what GM is basically
done is they put the power plant in the
trunk mm-hmm they they force you to give
up one of the seats or you've got only
four seats in a five seater and and it's
full short on gun on two fronts one it's
expensive all right it's a forty
thousand dollar car it's a sort of a
twenty-thousand-dollar sedan that cost
forty thousand dollars to buy and that
that's not gonna solve the problem
because not a lot of people can finance
a forty thousand dollar cart today for
assuming you make the money back with
your cost savings that movie but you
need to convince the consumer to get off
the one problem eighty-five percent of
the consumer decision at a dealership is
the price of the car so you're coming in
and saying and it was very well
articulated in the Wall Street Journal
article called one vault to priuses
which would you take hmm okay so so that
was sort of that's the starting point
the second point is you got a battery
that's bolted on and in in the ultimate
wisdom and the car
industry the car guys always tell you
wait until the next battery it's going
to be so great like that's gonna
convince you to go by tomorrow morning
it's like the they're building in the
Osborne syndrome into the car Yeah right
come buy this car the next battery will
be best and you won't be able to sell
your car ok so it's it's like you're
going into the classic early adopters so
people want to feel like they bought the
the Newton right and in knowing that
there is going to be something else
right after it and the two combos are
just devastating to the decision process
that happens at the dealership so so
that the problem being that is expensive
and you're locked into chula battery
technology do we have some miracle
battery coming down the road the McCain
300 million dollar research project the
the problem with with the miracle
battery is that it doesn't solve any
problem let's assume for a second that
we have a battery that knows how to
charge 300 miles in three minutes okay
sort of the gas tank equivalence mm-hm
if if you could do that you're plugging
you 300 mile batteries 75 kilowatt hours
and I know your physics guy so I can
talk kilowatt hours if you charge it in
three minutes you got to apply 20 times
more power because it's an hour divided
by three is 20 so you're you're plugging
in 20 x 75 that's one and a half
megawatts into the car no one and a half
megawatts comes with a sticker on the
steering wheel please leave the car take
your kids go behind the wall if when you
come back you don't have that problem
but I will if your hair standing up
that's just static don't worry
a Megan Megan half is people can't
fathom that but 750 apartments turning
on and off every single appliance one
shot I was at Berkeley today I said
let's go play that trick on PG&E will go
to the dorms and everybody will turn on
and off one shot every appliance every
two minutes it was a PG&E guy and he
looked at me with terrified face I said
now imagine a thousand of these stations
across the state what happens to the
graces it's fried so even if you had the
battery you don't know how to charge it
so it's your you're digging in the wrong
the wrong place so you're assuming that
battery technology will improve another
modest level pretty much I mean I guess
I should ask this question are you no
way are there enough batteries out there
we have you know you're competing with
every laptop in the world every cell
phone in the world you need what
hundreds if not thousands of these that
reason so so two things one we have a
Moore's curve for batteries is it a
motor skirt yeah it's it did we double
energy density every five years okay so
it's sort of the Moore's law of
batteries is not eighteen months it's
five years so assume that five years
after we come out with the battery that
can go 120 150 miles will come out with
the battery that goes 150 miles but
it'll be half size and half-priced and
then you know five years later you come
up with a battery that does 150 miles
but it'll be half so you don't need to
carry 300 miles if you can switch
batteries there's there's no sense but
what you'll have there'll be two bays
and if you really want to go long you'll
have two batteries of the durational
long drive not better will come off at
the other end how's that drive let me
get to get us S or scale here a hundred
thousand a better place of cars in the
Bay Area if that many in Israel Israel
will scale by the end of 2011 to about
eight thousand a month so the hundred
thousand year roughly Denmark a little
smaller I think Denmark will go faster
faster and market Denmark put a hundred
and eighty percent tax on gasoline cars
& 0
Electric 180 so a car crossed twice but
if you buy a Camry sixty thousand euro
if you buy the electric equivalents
twenty thousand euro if you still buy
the camry when there isn't available
electric car they want you to move to
Norway sort of you failed the IQ test
Israel x-ray I'm at Australia another
hundred thousand we as a 15 million car
country so it buys about a million and a
half cars a year our expectation
Australia's is it's roughly gonna be in
the half a million three four hundred
thousand when it starts ramping and you
may have some other announcements coming
out of other places we're looking we're
looking at you on the order of maybe
half million cars a year they will scale
fairly quickly to half a million a
million cars okay million cars a year in
each one of these cars says how many
batteries lots thousands think of it as
the today's collective lithium-ion
battery industry can serve about a
hundred thousand electric cars service
if a year so you basically you know
you're not competing with all the
laptops and cell phones in the world but
you actually ate five times as much
you're creating a new market for them
because we're willing to pay more money
for the battery because we're replacing
oil versus sort of prices that and it's
a different a bit different chemistry in
the sense that we we don't take
batteries of fit in laptops we actually
take batteries that don't explode yes
handy that but just just to give me ham
just to get a sense of scale here I mean
you're not just you know reinventing the
grid reinventing and you know the car
reinventing you know the renewable
energy you're also creating the biggest
lithium-ion battery consumer on the
planet by a factor of like five to ten
so so we've been optimistic I'm gonna be
a bit pest maybe a bit pessimistic we
there's a number from MIT that's been
running around in this industry now it
says by 2016 will have ten million
electric cars on the road it's the most
optimistic and most pessimistic study at
the same time to go from a hundred
thousand cars in 2011 10 million cars
2016 five years later we need to scale
an entire industry entire supply chain
by a factor of 100 x this is building
three Google's in five years to
Microsoft's in five years unfortunately
this is not in bits this is not on
websites this is in in
folding metals and chemistry and and
supply chain it's in it's the biggest
industrial growth you've ever seen on
the other hand if we only got 10 million
cars by 2016 we got 490 million gasoline
cars until then there's no planet
there's no economy there's there's there
are no cargo there will most car
companies on anyway but there's there's
a big meltdown so if you look at it from
for a perspective of what needs to get
done we need 100 million cars in 2016 a
thousand fold increase and there are
only two countries in the world that
know how to do that china in the US so
somebody needs to come up and either
have a plan in the u.s. because we know
how to do it we did it in 1941 hmm all
right we we sort of stop making cars
made tanks we just forgot to call them
and say stop making big tanks makes more
cars and the Chinese will do it the
Chinese way they'll come up and say this
city makes cars that city makes engine
that city makes battery that city makes
our electronics that city makes all the
stuff you need to connect 50 million
people you move here and that's in
they've just kick-started car 20 in
China am i hearing you right that your
plan is for the Chinese to copy you and
do it do it themselves I think so that's
in your phone that it look if China
announces that it's gonna do that the US
will have to do it the Europeans will
figure out they have to do that and I'm
sort of done I can quit I was gonna ask
one last question which is that's the
optimistic scenario yeah by which you
get pirated on a massive scale how could
it go wrong now what's what's you know
when you put what keeps you away tonight
huh depending if it's a good night or a
bad night let's go for the bad night bad
night one hundred fifty dollars a barrel
I'm fifty dollars a barrel two hundred
dollars a barrel you get a massive
geopolitical dislocation because we
can't afford mean look at one hundred
fifty dollars a barrel we paid 700
billion dollars a year and it sounds
familiar that number 700 le knows if we
do it 23 years the the green the green
is a piece of paper so that's you as a
world citizen what about you as a CEO of
a company oh that's the good night
that's if the the battery exchange
system takes four minutes instead of
three minutes I mean that's that's the
scope of the the technological problem
we got are so small so my new compared
to the the massive problem we're
tackling it there is there is no science
in it I mean is this is yeah you know
it's basic robotics we the funny part
robotics look you know robotics we have
a single dimensional arm going up and
down how hard can that be we'll find out